ah Sonia laying wanted to try streaming  yeah I wouldn't I would recommend trying  it never know how it is until you you  start actually I wanted to start doing  chest contents long before I actually  started took a while to get comfortable  like talking in front of the camera up  in front of like virtual people okay  Safford gamba time favorite opening  favorite opening to play against like a  lower rated players because there's just  so many traps chef g5  oh no my queen my beautiful Queen well  the game or the game maybe I'll put that  on YouTube I've had like so many games  like this never gets old though YouTube  people thanks for watching I'll see you  in the future